albert breer of sports illustrated how
are you albert
i'm good rich i hope you're at peace you
don't have any tips that you need to uh
you need to kind of reveal here well
yeah
we're live on the air albert
[Laughter]
i just want to let you know that
uh before we get to julio jones and all
that uh
how do you read aaron roush is not
showing up today how do you know
i mean you know i i think it would have
been an enormous surprise if he had
shown up and the main reason why is that
this is about money
um you know then you know like if five
hundred thousand dollars for
showing up for the rest of the
off-season program program wasn't gonna
motivate him to show up then why would
93 grand
um for showing up too many can't
motivate them that's the way i look at
it anyway
and we'll see whether or not the packers
decide to levy that fine
um but i think it just sort of means
where we're where we have been for a few
months
now and um you know the packers have
obviously
tried to pull every lever to get him
back in and you know i think a huge part
of the problem remains
um kind of a divide philosophically on
how the team's being built and the
communication over the
um over the jordan loves thing a year
ago so
i think it remains a very very
unpredictable thing but i don't think
the mini camp was ever
more than a checkpoint in this whole
thing rich i think when the rubber
beats road is and really has been the
whole time to start a training camp
are they talking to each other best you
can tell do you know
i know the packers have made efforts um
and i know the packers have made
multiple trips to california to meet
with them
um i don't know how much direct
communication
there's been over the last few weeks you
know
i'll give the packers credit for this
you know and i i can give you some
insight in my own reporting
um you know i i think the packers have
made an effort
not to sort of work the back rooms so to
speak on this
and you know what mark murphy did on the
team website
borderline unprecedented i don't know if
i've ever seen a team use this website
that way before
uh you know the other day you know and
then you know if you want to
add on to that like you know my
experience was and they've actually
asked me
to go on the record in a couple
different circumstances because
um you know they don't want to be saying
anything in the background
um and sort of working that part of the
game they want to be transparent about
it i think that's a message to aaron
which is
you know we're going to try to be as
principled as we can be about this and
when we talk about you
we're going to do it publicly we're not
going to be trying anything behind your
back or anything like that
so the packers are doing i think
everything they can to try to get them
back on board i think the trouble is
how much can they really show him at
this point um
how things are going to be different
because we are we're obviously an
appointment calendar now we're
well past the end of free agency julio
jones has now been traded the draft was
a month ago
i don't know what else you can do to
show aaron rodgers that you're going to
build the team any differently that you
have for the last 30 years well i mean
and and and that's part of the problem
albert is that
we we've got we've got a situation
that is now uh well let's do the right
math here
uh 14 15 months old that you can't
change
and then you have as you pointed out all
the team-building scenarios that
that um you know could prove to aaron
rodgers that we hear
you and that the only thing that could
be
you know used as a public apology
without saying i'm sorry about 15 months
ago
would be either to trade the guy in
jordan love or give
rogers a contract that means jordan love
will not get on the field
uh in time for them to properly evaluate
him for a fifth year option
and the question is is would that even
satisfy aaron rodgers at that point in
time
that's have i have i kind of captured it
or what here i mean i can tell you
yeah i mean they've offered them
contracts you know and so
i think get right on to think about like
i think you're right on to think about
the guaranteed money and i think that
that's what everybody needs to pay
closer attention to
you know we can throw around big numbers
all we want whatever number they're
going to give internationally a big one
you know i think the
key is how do you prove to him you're
going to be a quarterback for the next
three years
that would require by the way rich the
packers doing something else they
generally don't do
if you look at the packers big contracts
normally they have
enormous signing bonuses and they don't
guarantee future years
so they would have to break the way they
do business there too
to really show aaron rodgers we're
locking into you for the next two or
three years
um you know and and three years would be
you know
getting to the extent to the end of
jordan loves
rookie contract where you know you'd
have to be beyond the past where he'd
make a decision on his fifth year option
so um yeah i mean i think that there's
some stuff that they can do
contractually
um that would definitely you know signal
to aaron rodgers he's the guy going
forward but i can tell you
that they've already put stuff in front
of them and said
we're going to give you a new contract
and that hasn't really blew
all that much albert brier here on the
rich eisen show well i mean the aaron
jones contract is uh
you know on the credit card um where the
number of years that's on his contract
is beyond what they would absolutely
consider keeping him at i wouldn't think
it's certainly at that position and the
two years in which he's viable under the
cap is
maybe rogers remaining years there
unless of course he's like brady and he
wants to play tilly's 40 and you turn
jordan love into jimmy garoppolo you
know
so put it all put it all together for me
albert and
let's give gouda kunst a little bit of
run here just briefly
what do you think i mean they have like
i mean that's the thing is they have
mortgage some contracts
so i think you got to give them credit
for that because that's not something
they'd normally
do and you know they mortgaged the
darius smith contract president smith
everyone in the league
thought that he was going to be the
treasurer they kept him right like and
that's a piece that normally you know a
team that's looking a long range would
say well we drafted rashaan gary
you know a couple of years ago so maybe
it's just time to move on from a big
number but they mortgaged preston smith
to keep another good player on the
roster
and so you know i i think they have done
some things that are
a little out of left field for them you
know and
i think you have to give them some
credit that they have
in certain ways broken from the way
they've done business in the past
i just think you know a big piece of
this and i've probably said this to you
three or four times
on the air i think a big piece of this
was you know aaron rodgers looking
around
um after they lost in the championship
game looking at the other three teams in
particular
and looking at how aggressively the
chiefs have built around patrick mahomes
how aggressively the bills have drafted
around
where i've built around josh allen and
in particular how the buccaneers have
just gone all out
and said we don't care what happens in
2023 we're going to put a super team
around tom brady
and i think that that's something that
russell wilson took note of to where
now i think a lot of the quarterbacks
this is what i'm up against i want
to be in a place where they're going to
build around me that way where
everything is
you know kind of predicated on my window
to win a championship
hey man i've been saying this since
pretty much brady won it all and you
first heard rogers
um you know uh after losing to brady in
the nfc championship game say something
that caused us to say what's he talking
about now that
five-alarm fire is has got the entire
packers organization aflame
over this one situation and so you know
put it all together maybe a way of doing
things you could just
make an exception for your goat 12 in
the same way that
the bucks have clearly done um if you're
a green bay
so put it all together if gurdacoon's
brian guticun's the
the the chief grocery shopper there in
green bay and
and the supposed target of roger's
biggest
problem what stuck in rogers crawl the
most
if he had a moment to just be thoroughly
truthful stuff's not going to get
out he could just vent what do you think
he'd want everyone to know
albert what do you think i think he
would say i think he would say
look at our roster right i think that's
what he would say
i think he would say look at what we've
done like
you were upset earlier in your career
that the team wasn't
more aggressive in free agency we
brought in zadaria smith from baltimore
preston smith from washington and adrian
amos from chicago we also
put an offer sheet in front of kyle ford
that didn't work out we've been
aggressive since i've been the general
manager
that's number one we are drafting really
well right now and you look at the
younger players in the roster guys like
kenny clark rashawn gary jair alexander
um
you know you've got infrastructure here
we've held on to our own
you know we've drafted devante adams and
we've drafted
david back to yari and you know like you
said rich
aaron jones and we've paid those guys
so you know i think what brian good
acounts would say
is look around and realize what you've
got here
because the grass isn't always greener
on the other side
and i mean let me ask you this rich
if you were starting an nfl team how
many rosters would you take over the
packers
take the quarterbacks out of it oh okay
i was about to say that okay
take the quarterbacks out of it um right
no i if you were a quarter
if you're a quarterback and say say
you're a quarterback so you're a 38 year
old quarterback you got one year to win
right how many places would you go
before you go to green bay
and there's no question that if let's
say roger was having this problem in
indianapolis let's just choose any team
in the other conference
let's just say he was the goat in
indianapolis and the general manager
there let's just say
chris ballard was in the role of gouda
kunst even though they're totally
different people
and he's looking around where can i win
right now he'd look at green bay
you know what i'm saying like so so
green i don't think there's any question
certainly since anybody who is late in
their career doesn't want to
have to change their routine you know
what i mean they don't have to they
don't want to change anything that they
they they also
know the facility but they also do see
what brady did after 20 years and they
want that
you know so i don't i guess again like
what is what's the answer only 12 knows
only rogers knows that that's what it is
that's the thing
that's what makes it so unpredictable
rich and you know we've we've talked a
lot about
you know on the last five months i think
it was i think it was adam that had the
tweet
earlier in the off season about like
half the league's quarterback situations
potentially being in flux
um you know and i i i think like it's
fair to say
it's probably been kind of like half and
half right like half
of what we thought was going to happen
have happened happened
half of what people maybe thought might
happen hasn't happened right
so i just i think the other pieces that
people are failing to look at
look at the situations of the teams the
traded quarterbacks and look at the
situation of teams that did
detroit traded its quarterback they're
on a total rebuild with a first year
coach
the eagles traded their quarterback
they're in a rebuild with a first year
coach
the teams that didn't seattle older head
coach
and a team has been competitive
consistently and a lot of players that
could probably wagner
jamal adams that are in their prime
packers
one of the best rosters in the league a
lot of guys at 27
28 29 years old in a win-now window and
so i think sometimes when we've looked
at
kind of the way that the quarterback
movements happen this offseason and all
the
you know the cage rattling all that
different stuff that's happened
i'm looking enough at is look at the
teams willing to move their quarterbacks
worse versus the teams that aren't
willing to move their quarterbacks the
ones that are willing to move the
quarterbacks
are kind of in a i guess throw your
hands up and we're starting over
type of place right where the teams that
aren't the teams that they're more
resistant why are they more resistant
well because the rest of the roster you
look at the rest of the roster what's
fair to the rest of the roster
the fair was fair to the rest of the
roster that's been competing
you know contending for the last few
years is to hold the line with the
quarterback you know
so i think that's the piece of it that
people are missing
when they're when when you're looking at
all this and you know even like you look
at houston and deshaun watson and maybe
they're willing just to listen
to sean watson now why would they move
on from a 25 year old
you know and this quarterback other than
the obvious going on legally
a part of it is that nick casario and
david collier are completely starting
over there
so like i just think that that's one
piece of it that people haven't paid
enough attention to it's not the spot
the players in it's also the spot the
team's in
before i let you go albert breer uh
great column yesterday
on the genesis and the completion of the
julio jones trade
if you could boil it down to a few
minutes here uh why did he go
and how did he get to tennessee best you
can tell
yeah yeah i i think i saw something from
your show yesterday where you were
talking about like the price
right like so it's a two and a four with
a six coming back with him and i know i
know a lot of people
look at that say well wow like you know
why couldn't we have him for that
um i think it's complex you know and i
think
part of it is the price tag um how much
he costs
i think a part of it's his injury
history the fact that you know
he probably isn't going to be able to
practice for you day to day you're going
to have to manage him a certain way
which certain coaches have feelings
about their best players being
in that sort of position especially when
they're new um
yeah but i think the the the main thing
is the age
and you know i've looked back at this um
you know over the last few weeks
there have been 11 trades of
non-quarterbacks for first-round picks
over the last i think it's four years
right
every one of those players was 27 years
old or younger
um julio's 32 um then i went another
five years back the oldest player i
could find
the previous five years was jimmy graham
who was 28 right
i like i can't find a non-quarterback in
nfl i
i i just couldn't find one maybe there
is one i couldn't find a non-quarterback
over 30 in nfl history who was traded
for a first-round pick
it's right or wrong it's what the league
is the league is the pays generally and
the league doesn't poor
big draft capital space oh i think
that's why the price tag was where it
was and
um yeah i think the other important
thing to remember here and this is sort
of how i led that column
this has been two years in the making
and i don't think that anybody should be
pointing a finger at who at
terry fontenot or arthur smith in
atlanta
um i think this really goes back to
contract negotiation two years ago and
quietly at one point julio actually
asked out then
this is two years ago um he's basically
told the team i wouldn't mind being
traded if we can't get a new contract
done
and really i think that had a chilling
effect of a relationship between the
organization
and the player and then you know i think
the one guy who was sort of who
was confidant through all that was dan
quinn i think
once they fired dan quinn and i'm not
saying they were wrong for doing it but
once they fired dan quinn last october
and that was sort of the last piece of
the relationship
maybe the last piece of jenga tower
getting pulled out you know and i think
at that point
sort of became a complete where the
falcons were going to have these cap
problems they've got five guys on the
roster dion jones jake matthews grady
chair
matt ryan and julio jones with huge
numbers
julio wanted out and i mean because of
where he was and the way he felt about
everything
it made sense to to move him over the
other four
and did the falcons freak when uh when
he said what he said on the air without
knowing he was on the air
did they did they lose their minds yeah
i mean they were upset they were very
upset i mean i can tell you that
because that they worked really hard to
kind of keep
most of this under wraps and to be able
to you know keep it quiet that that
julia wanted out for almost two years
um or that julio had asked for that two
years ago
and then you know the the face-to-face
conversation or the the
the man-to-man conversation that arthur
smith and julio jones had where
uh you know arthur basically promised
julio
we're not gonna let this get out that
you've asked for a trade
um in fact they worked so hard for two
and a half months to to do that
the whole thing came apart because julio
was caught off guard and didn't know he
was on tv he
thought he was just talking to a buddy
of his on the phone and if you've
listened to julio's tone
rich i'm sure you could pick up like
that's what it sounded like he thought
the setting was
um you know i think that's why the
falcons were so upset about it i don't
know if it went to the league level or
if we talk
fox or anything like that but i i do
know um
i do know the falcons had a pretty big
issue with with julio being put in that
spot
albert you the man appreciate it let's
uh let's catch up next week let's keep
doing this
there's lots going on lots of mandatory
mini camps over the next two weeks so
thanks for the call
you're the man you got it right albert
breer on twitter i follow him you should
too
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here